STACY WOLF: "Why
music theater?" is
the question we asked ourselves
as soon as we wanted to start
this program at Princeton.
And we are excited that
we can have this kind
of expansive vision in a place
because we're small, we're
very undergraduate focused,
we're completely collaborative
in everything we do.
Wherever the student
is coming from in terms
of the art, that can lead.
So the theater, the text can
lead, the music can lead,
the composition can lead,
or the dance can lead.
And we are supportive
of any of those balances
among these different forms.
We don't have an agenda in
terms of what music theater
creation can mean at Princeton.
We are excited to see where
students are coming from
and how we can help
them as artists
and as scholars
to make new stuff.
I'm Stacy Wolf.
I'm a professor in
the program in theater
at the Lewis Center for the
Arts at Princeton University,
and I'm the director of
Princeton's new Program
in Music Theater.
WESLEY CORNWELL: Princeton for
me is this great combination
of the academic side and then
the creative side with faculty
that are really there to support
you every step of the way,
from visual research
to scene breakdowns
to technical drawings
or costume sketches
through tech all the
way to the performance.
OGE UDE: The school has been
incredibly supportive in terms
of just giving me the funding
to get where I want to go.
I know exactly
what I want to do.
And oftentimes, it lives
outside of what is available.
And I think Princeton has been
really supportive of getting me
to that very
specific, niche place
that I have said that I'm
very passionate about.
JULIA PEIPERl: I have
had this guidance that
has helped me to
radically increase
the quality of my
work, or at least
the quality of my research
and the foundations
that are going into my work.
And that's because
of the classes
that I've gotten to take.
STACY WOLF: And we very
much pride ourselves
on balancing scholarly
pursuits and artistic pursuits,
performance and creation.
All of our students are scholar-
artists and artist-scholars.
We do not see the difference
between making scholarship
and making art.
WESLEY CORNWELL: And you
have an incredible diversity
of academic backgrounds
all being brought
into the same classroom
for the same project,
asking the same questions.
And that diversity of
academic thoughts, I think
yields so many more
interesting results.
The combination of intellectual
rigor and creativity
is really astonishing
and something
I've found immensely rewarding.
STACY WOLF: We've had
directors, designers, critics,
musical directors.
And they come to class and
talk about what they've done,
how they've made their careers.
They engage with the students.
And because we're so
close to New York,
it's very easy for them
to hop on the train
and come and spend
an afternoon with us.
And to have access to
artists in that way
is absolutely
unique and amazing.
DEAN MOSS: What I
like about students,
and Princeton students in
particular, is their openness.
They come from a wide range
of academic experience
that they bring to the
art-making process.
And it's their love of making
art that forces this to happen.
And I have been excited
by that engagement
and what they
bring to the table.
BILLY COHEN: The resources
are obviously crazy,
but what I like about it
is the professors take
a genuine interest in
each and every student,
no matter what
their background is
or what they plan on doing
with theater or musical theater
in the future.
They really focus on bringing
to life what each student is
capable of doing every day.
STACY WOLF: This program very
specifically is music theater,
so it does include
the Broadway musical.
It also includes opera.
We have a very strong opera
program here as well as
what we think of as more
avant garde music theater,
different ways that music
theater, dance, text
and performance
all come together
to make an entirely
new hybrid form.
[MUSIC PLAYING]